the man considered the founding father
of pakistan's nuclear program has died
the interior ministry announced the
death of abdul qadir khan after he was
in hospital with kovitt 19. the
scientists had long courted
international controversy accused of
selling nuclear secrets to libya north
korea and iran but in pakistan he's
considered a national icon for
transforming the country into a nuclear
power
bidding farewell to their hero
not even the pouring rain could keep
thousands from attending abdul qadir
khan's state funeral in islamabad
the man was a symbol of pride for
pakistan particularly in its relations
with regional rival india a
long-standing nuclear power yesterday a
great man died
he was a great scientist he served this
country
he served this country with emotion
dignity respect
and with hard work so whole pakistani
nation salutes him
and he is going to be buried as a
with all highly official respects
khan might have been a hero in his
country but outside he was notorious his
team helped pakistan carry out a nuclear
test in 1998 which resulted in
international sanctions on the country
the united nations nuclear watchdog
named khan as a key figure in a global
atomic black market
in 2004 he confessed to illegally
sharing nuclear secrets with iran libya
and north korea
i wish to play
that those of my subordinates who have
accepted their role in the affair were
acting in good faith like me
on my instructions i also wish to
clarify
that there was never ever any kind of
authorization for these activities
by the government
i take full responsibility for my
actions and seek your pardon
pakistan's then military ruler pervez
musharraf placed khan under house arrest
in 2004. a lenient punishment which
angered the west
khan lived mostly out of the public eye
following his release five years later
his death has brought him back into view
polarizing opinion at home and abroad
joining me now from karachi in pakistan
it's professor perez hubby he's a
nuclear physicist and he also sat on the
un's advisory board on disarmament
matters a professor as an anti-nuclear
activist which you are what legacy do
you feel abdul khadija khan leaves
behind
well he
certainly initiated the uranium
enrichment program because he was
employed at urenko in belgium and there
he chanced upon those documents that he
was given to translate and so yes
i think that the uranium enrichment
program owes to him
however the actual fabrication of the
bomb the design and act and the testing
does not come from him it comes from the
pakistan atomic energy commission and
the
the
atomic energy commission and khan's
institute were at loggerheads they were
bitter rivals as far as his being a
scientist he's always
advertised in the news as a nuclear
scientist he was not
he was a metallurgist and
i think his greatest contribution was uh
perhaps in
in reverse engineering
i also i think that uh what you have
just played
doesn't convey the fact that he died a
very bitter man and he
thought that
he had been robbed of his legacy
that the army
who had
in fact recruited him and
under and which worked essentially under
him betrayed him
in
the matter of professor
because we briefly interrupted here
because you talked about his legacy many
analysts say that nuclear deterrence
between india and pakistan worked in
preventing them from going to war with
each other
was he responsible for for that at least
in part
no i don't think he had anything to do
with policy the fact that pakistan has
nuclear weapons
of course prevents
india and pakistan from going to war
against each other however
very interestingly it was nuclear
weapons that initiated the cargill
conflict and this was one in which about
three to four thousand people died on
both sides and this is a war that would
not have occurred but for the existence
of nuclear weapons because pakistan felt
itself sufficiently secure
and so it felt that it could
it could uh send
troops disguised of course across the
international border across the line of
control and that's what caused the
conflict so it's i think a very unique
case of nuclear weapons actually causing
a war
professor purvis hood boy physicist and
antinuclear activist thank you very much
you